qui ici est contre le pass vaccinale dit
la vérité merci je le savais pas j'ai
gardé un oui parce qu'on va laisser je
partage pas toutes vos convictions mais
on va laisser des gens sur le bas côté
et beaucoup l'un dans le pays d'olmes et
c'est pour moi on ne sait pas s'il
allait oui on ne sait pas exactement ce
qu'il ya dans le vaccin vaccinale dans
le public aussi merci et alors vous
savez pas oui il ya des gens qui
hésitent et on les laisse sur le bas
côté des mauvais citoyens moi je n'aime
pas qui a des mauvais citoyen débrancher
que j'ai eu un accueil aussi vrai bien
sûr que je suis contre et puis à partir
du moment où même des gens sont vaccinés
ils sont invités à aller à ces
manifestations pour manifester contre le
palais national qui n'a aucun rapport
avec le vaccin bien sûr lui réponds moi
se dit jeudi à cette hypocrisie elle
m'énerve moi de sortir les gens du
travail que parce que bon florian
philippot c'est pas grave pour lui il
fera quand même des trucs il y aura
quand même travailler il fera mais il ya
des gens compétents qui
lui travaille ça changera il aura deux
mais qu'il emmènera en bagnole à droite
à gauche mais il est vrais gens qui
perdent leur boulot pour le
connais bien comprenez bien quand vous
dites 7000 7000 les autres vous aussi
7000 donc c'est pas le problème je vous
dis pas ce que je dis
jeudi jusqu'à un moment donné non je
passe à autre chose avait alors dit nous
que pourquoi t'es content moi je suis
content parce que justement on pour 6
millions de gens je les ai dit hier on
va priver tout une toute une partie de
gens de leur taf de leur sortie j'étais
je suis toujours contre la ville la
vaccination des enfants de 6 ans onze
ans c'est une connerie pour moi moi je
vous dis vous voulez que je dise le fond
de ma pensée je vous le dire j'aurais
préféré que roger puisque vous allez me
dire je vous le dire j'aurais préféré
que ce soit vaccination obligatoire
alors arrête de couler
et vous faites là bas
j'aime venir il ya énormément j'ai eu au
téléphone le wiki moyens comme un lion
qui m'ont dit tu sais bon on aurait
préféré un truc francs c'est bien vous
savez quoi ces vaccinations obligatoires
vous avez d'ailleurs le cas du parlement
il a dit hey on assume et emma bernard
montiel excusez moi c'est une dictature
c'est par
être étudié au même tu en as tu auras
pas bouffer ton enfant de 10 ans il
rappe en sport il restera chez les
regardera par la fenêtre c'est déjà jcpa
sur berne à seurre c'est déjà comme ça
bien sûr j'aurais préféré qu'on dit ça
aurait pu n'être qu'en dise le policier
qui va aller dans la rue eh ben il sera
pas vacciner l'enseignante alors le
choix de pas se faire vacciner le
routier et aura soit pas ses racines et
qu'est ce que c'est que ce bordel
moi j'ai fait je fais partie de ceux
qu'on fait l'armée je suis arrivé à
l'armée comme ça moi j'ai donné mes bras
magath qui mettait dedans et spider-man
ils m'ont mis dans le bon ils m'ont
piqué je ne savais pas je sais après
c'est pour ça
aujourd'hui on a laissé des portes de
sortie aux gens et on a expliqué aux
gens et maintenant il ya des études et
on leur explique que le vaccin est
dangereux et maintenant vous pleurer
parce que les gens se renseignent
évidemment que les gestes renseigner
passe vers le cinéma quitté obama est là
mais aujourd'hui il n'y avait pas
internet dont j'ai fait là maintenant ce
qu'il faut c'est dire aux gens essayer
de les combats et si vous n'arrivez pas
à les convaincre pas foutez leur la paix
[ __ ] merde laissez les tranquille ça
passe et passe à qui tu te diriges
autant qu'il voit bien le tarif d'accès
à l'eau si oui non mais on dit
vaccination des garçons et on voit bien
que ce vaccin il ne sert à rien et il a
une chantage géant mais c'est du
chantage de dire à ton en fosse 12 mois
guillaume de dire à ton enfant dix ans
s'il se vaccinent pas il regardera les
autres par la fenêtre joue au football
mais quelqu'un qui sait qui fait ça qui
fait ça personne ne fait ça elle n'était
pas vaccinée du rap au travail demain tu
resteras chez toi l'infirmière a sauvé
n'éviter pas vaccinés rentre chez toi tu
rêves dauphin qui fait ça mais vous êtes
paré les mêmes incompris par est oui
pour
moi j'aime pas c'est quoi la maxime
rajab aussi à l'hommage a pas de
relation avait ferraillé dur fascistes
ont démarré